okay so we're going to uh go over that
same concept so I'm not I'm not moving
him externally but I do want his Center
to travel through space
into the kazushi patterns either the
front end or the buck outward Etc okay
so I don't ever throw him down under me
unless you wanted to but in that would
be a pin you you want to throw an
opponent down under you you better be
ready for your ground fighting or your
stomping
okay but in Nick a nugget was that we
should throw them away from us okay so
like in that one shivanaga I did
I was throwing him away from me but I
stayed up with him so he ended up under
me and then you went for a pin and a
strike okay
uh here we'll do get we'll do Joe Don
again
okay so you have to pass through the
phases you can't you don't just do joke
on like that
you're not you're not escaping you're
getting his Center and you're moving his
Center okay
so we want the fight to rotate home
until I come this way
okay down he goes all right here here is
another part where we're going to get to
that same thing so as he stands up I'm
moving that and then same thing don't go
here
keep
the same connection yeah
as he stands up the same ikey connection
that is here on that path it now picks
up on this hand and it does
the same thing keeps him going
[Music]
oh
it's not that I'm going here
uh I'm not trying to arm Bob him I
resist
I am moving his center from there
okay if I try to arm bar him and he
resists it's not
resist I can move his Center
same thing as I understand
okay same thing
same thing here same thing there
foreign
[Music]
on the inner portion of your arm okay
don't just knock him over let's go
[Music]
foreign
okay did you notice how your hand three
out of four reps you're throwing arm
your young arm and the technique did not
even touch her
only one time it touched and only
briefly into the throwing Arc and then
she's falling okay
so you know we had the technique
okay I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do that
but I'm not I'm not doing it externally
either
some of you were like uh Center up
extend your arm wait he's gonna have
four way more leverage now do you see
don't hurt me again just I can't I can't
hold it even two hands he has way more
leverage now I can't do it
what I what I was doing instead is as as
he resists that energy I project out do
you see and then I've I stayed up with
his falling hat
totally different
just like
it's not that I'm that I'm shoving them
down I'm not pulling them from the out
to the end he's gonna resist I project
that forward but I don't stay still
though I project not moving myself
at a ring and in a space where I can
keep projecting and all my hand is doing
is staying up with him
so any any projection you can't project
with your fingertips so he goes to stand
up you can keep projecting but I can't
stay still or my hat will come off so he
goes to stand up I project I project I
reject I project and it's just with
figurative
same thing here I'll give a an egregious
example which is very common here
oh yeah
you see I'm pulling it
okay
he summoned me
and his energy is going forward
all right energy is going that way
and I'm gonna pull
no no I'm not I'm not gonna okay
so instead
let's say
I'm here and again you see the
fingertips and his energy is going
forward and each one I just keep
projecting you see
each little increment he'll resist again
and I keep projecting and what I'm doing
with my turning is staying so my is
moving at a rate and at a rotation that
my hand stays in place it's not that I'm
so for example let's say I don't even
know if this will work you come here
and you you're going to help him you're
going to help him go that way you can
see no no way that's not gonna work okay
so what I'm gonna do as he pulls I just
keep grounding you can feel how much
tired I stand on your neck you
so talk and you'll see
yeah okay
same thing goes for example
and this is where I wanted to get to
same thing goes here on the throat okay
oh you guys are going around
or you're trying to shove them down
or your kid does it for you
see
so he comes here and your UK does it for
you
[Music]
so same thing as I get you're going to
reach the the yin space so the young
cycle only goes so far on that hand and
on that energy going forward so he's
going forward and I keep moving it off
the ground now it's done he's gonna get
up I can do it for a little but now it's
off again it's injured it's getting it's
Yin phase okay and that should be where
the second hand comes over but now the
second hand doesn't do one of those two
options go around or mayuka fall or
shove them down
so for example if he does not fall down
and he's resisted
well nothing's gonna happen if he's
resisting and he's stronger than me but
it's nothing's gonna happen but if I
keep taking his resistance go and I
project you see he wants to keep falling
Folly folly and then what is my arm
doing just staying up so that it can
keep projecting it's not throwing him
okay
boom
maybe you can see his body is Unified
doesn't sling and there's constant
connection but I'm not wrestling
okay try it again
foreign
you're not touching her head
so resist
you can see how so you're trying to pull
your right arm do you see that but the
right arms already entered its Yin face
do you understand there's no there's no
more there here's where the left arm
Yong phase is supposed to begin but
she's resisting and there's this there's
no way because you weren't doing it the
other way you were having her fall for
you so she's resisting
and you're trying to go around it you
see you're trying to do an external
non-contestation
she's trying to go around the leverage
point
and of course my my UK has only been
asked to be strong hasn't been asked to
try to get up try to turn in do you
understand
you know now you're trying to push the
obvious material of her her chest and
upper torso did you feel that
now we're going around everything okay
all right here we are got it and resist
you can see there's nothing more on that
there's nothing more on my fingers you
see that hi okay so we're here at this
line
um so you're going to resist
well pay attention to what your body's
doing okay keep resisting
what do you feel
yeah you're first of all you're scared
as hell I'm not gonna throw you I just
want you to feel your body okay
keep resisting
keep more
there you go yes
okay uh
we're here sure if you want to be that
high
because normally you're here but I don't
it doesn't matter okay so uh you're
trying to be strong that's it and I just
keep projecting to the ground projecting
to the ground projecting to the ground
projecting to the ground projecting to
the ground okay now
instead of letting you
uh Fallout
where you'll see I want to point it out
to you resist boom there's the
projection instead of here you're
falling you see that
I use that falling energy to keep it
going this way
see that difference
so I don't I'm not going to let you fall
out free hi
your energy I keep using
you get it to go this way okay all right
try it again
okay so on the initial prescribed
energy print that okay has energy linear
going in the opposite direction that I
was going okay so I would be over here
so it's coming towards me okay and on
the first kazushi
it's the fact that that energy keeps
going that way that when I create a turn
this energy is still going that way
still going that way still going that
way through the incremental rotation
that's what allows him to stick to uh my
curvature that's why I don't have to
pull his uh collar or anything weird
like that okay so I'll show you what
that means that that's this is why in
that one example when Tristan pulls
ronin's
further that way it generated more
pressure at your neck remember and I
said look listen to your voice my
fingers are digging into you which they
can't if I'm just on the side but
because I'm turning and you're pulling
against this centripetal you're you're
actually generating this centripetal
energy in an equal and opposite way okay
so as his energies going that way
and if I take his uh that energy that's
going that way and I just am
incrementally it keeps going that way
incrementally you feel the pressure on
your neck you see that if I stop it and
pull it back there's it's not possible
if I try to shove it really fast past
its value it will lose it I do it at a
rate that is utilizing the energy that's
going that way so he's going that way
and I can keep pulling it you see
you see
you all right okay
how you what how you do that energy
though
because you're going to want to just
pull you're going to want to just pull
this down okay how you do that energy is
that energy that I feel on my fingertips
I am rotating it but every single pull
that he does I ground I ground it's
grounding it's grounding grounding
grounding grounding
it's not that I'm going like this you
won't get it that way okay it's the same
thing he's here okay and I ground to
project you can do it uh
he'll pull and I'll ground off the front
foot boom and you pre you can project
okay same exactly
that is the first position
as you pass into the yin phase of that
kazushi
he's gonna stand up for prescription in
the form okay he's gonna try to stand up
all right so as he stands up
that's where I make another of one of
those curves
and it's his his desire to stand up
that I keep projecting back down to the
ground and that creates that ikey
adhesion where I again don't have to
pull him
he stuck to me
and he is moving from projection to
projection to projection
so we got the first one we'll just get
there okay
here's his energy standing up do you see
and that energy standing up
occurred
on that same energy as he's going up I
keep uh
this curve here
okay uh but it's not that I'm moving my
arm externally he stands up and IT
projects you see he stands up IT
projects he stand up a little there up
and IT projects
that's what creates the IQ adhesion so
he goes warm and I keep this to here you
see
so it was your energy to the contrary
that I curved and now used to generate
the adhesion or friction at my touch
Point okay
then that Kazuki is going to pass into
yitz Yin phase on the other arm interest
into its yawn phase okay and that person
is resisting
so they have an energy that's going this
way
the on the other ones I had a kind of uh
inward orientation to my IQ adhesion and
this one's going to be an outward
orientation okay because my curve is now
going this way
okay and their energy is going into it
so every time they project they get
stuck on my inner arm
I take that energy I ground it I ground
it and that's what moves it
incrementally through the throat
foreign
so here we are this is why I don't have
to pull him I don't need to crank this
this arm's done this arm is now it okay
so this arm has the adhesion
this does it I'm not knocking them down
his Mass
has energy and that energy I ground
which gets Amplified on the person that
is resisting so he resists well that
makes more energy that I can both
to his arm he's using that arm you could
do it it doesn't matter he's using that
arm to base okay so push and I use that
arm and I project the arm out you see
that all right
so we're here but now you can feel that
it's starting to go off there's a little
bit you see but it's starting to go off
do you feel that right okay
in the why is it going off it's
because you're starting to fall
you're you're no longer offering that
resistance to this curve you're starting
to fall out of it so as we get further
up this increment gravity is starting to
generate another energy where you start
to fall this way start to fall down
towards the ground
okay
well
I can use that energy
to pass through
a young face into a Yin phase and now it
can still do the same thing as it's
pushing here
you get about an inch or two more
projection but again in combat inches
are Miles okay
so uh I want you you'll you'll feel I'll
try to tell you when to feel okay so
your energy is going that way that's
that friction point energy is coming up
that's that friction point you feel the
pulls on your finger okay then here is
that you feel that okay now as you start
to fall out of it you see how it went
off
but I can use this downward energy to
keep the same friction going
feel that
and what we tend to do is the guy's
falling and then we let them fall
but if you were to do an inward spiral
here
so is the same thing it doesn't stop
here it doesn't stop here
keeps going
and you watch his head you can see his
head that probably where it's visible
okay they're here it's in the center you
wash his head all exaggerated
jerking
back kind of like and the days you had
Harlem Globetrotters and they're passing
that ball back and forth okay all the
way the length of their arm all right
try it again
foreign
so if you pay attention
you're awake
went back
on the throat and your Center went up
okay this is the external this is that
the external yield to take energy off
right and then the up to to push them
away okay if I was doing it internally I
would sink down and I wouldn't have to
take energy off because the energy is
passing in between me so to get you on
the same page or for those who didn't
see it coming around
boom there's a lot of home you see and
you're gonna go around it you see the
yield right there and then in here
it's it's good to know but you want to
try to gain the internal aspect okay so
as as we already saw for example uh
you guys have seen he both both of my
sons now lift way more than me okay
um
so if I take
if I have one person even if I don't
keep racing angles you see last time he
used his bracelet I don't give him any
bracing angle
he resists I cannot do it I cannot do it
and if I do that
that Yin that external Yin yield it
creates a weakness here that no now he's
got me using
so
I have to just like the shiho Nagin I
have to take his resistance and keep
bouncing it through me it has to pass
through me in which case I can't go up
okay and in which case I can't do a
yield okay
so
um
just so you can say so be strong be
strong don't let me throw you don't want
me for you
there's just no there's no way my arm is
not strong enough okay
but again if you take the same he pushes
right and I take that energy I release
it down and I project it out you see I'm
projecting it out projecting it out
projecting the balance
if you add
his energy to it you see
same thing there's no way I'm strong
enough but I can keep projecting keep
projecting
keep projecting that energy
when the guy is standing
it's even tougher
because he has so much of his leg
strength
do you think
is like oh God no okay
and I want to know how to connect his
Center because I don't want my throw to
come from a pulling there's no pulling
you can't pull people
I wanted to come from moving his center
around itself okay so if he resist an
incredible now and I try to shop right
he'll move his feet no
but if he resists
I can turn him
doing the same thing that we drew on the
board so I use the same thing I'm going
to spin his center around by grounding
it
there we are
okay I have this energy and I'm going to
make it go on a circle
oh he's strong strong he's not going to
bend for me but I can spin it
boom here
pop
every every resistance every strength he
does I ground
to spin him
okay so if we're doing swadiwasa
don't milk
that he his quads have been taken out of
it okay try to do what we're doing
get throw the whole body the whole
Center
yes come on whole body there you go
don't don't don't get don't you got
Satisfied by the throw you let her out
the bottom keep projecting her away from
you into the throw that's what you need
for tachiwasa
spinner whole body
it's full whole body whole body better
they lengthen the second IQ adhesion
this one lengthen it yes whole body
there you go